new details are emerging tonight after
two brothers were arrested accused of
beating a man with a pipe the victim
dying a few days later and good evening
to you at 11 I'm Brian Loftus I'm Denise
Valdez on Monday 31 year old Anthony
Gregory casterhone died from his
injuries North Las Vegas Police say
these two men 19 year old Miguel Rosas
Gonzalez and 23 year old Jose Rosas
Gonzalez are facing charges that will
likely change after the man's death
Brian will joining us live from the
north Las Vegas jail now with more Brian
tonight both brothers are currently
facing both larceny and battery charges
I spoke to people who know Anthony
castron well and they tell me that wow
he had a rough upbringing he was working
on turning that around
Anthony just wanted everybody to have
what he did as a kid Anthony came from
rough beginnings and the gym saved his
life and he just wanted to be after
other people Anthony castrohon better
known by his gym nickname pretty boy was
a big part of the one kicks gym
Community a community still reeling from
the news of his death a lot of them are
in disbelief you know a lot of the kids
are really sad you know but they know
that he wanted him to train so they just
keep coming and just work through it
according to a North Las Vegas police
report castrohon was drunk last Friday
night threatening a woman's roommate
after she refused to go home with him
officers say he followed her on and off
a bus but once they both got off she
heard a loud thud when she turned around
she saw her friend Miguel roses Gonzalez
standing over castrohon holding a metal
pipe Gonzalez later told police that he
hit him twice with a metal pipe and took
castrohon's gun eventually fleeing the
scene with his brother Jose it's an
incident that doesn't have a good ending
for anyone keeping him out of the
streets was you know what we wanted to
do because he did have talent and we
wanted them to display it but you know
he lived in a rough part of town so you
know you're always worried about him
getting caught up with some you know
friends or whatever because you know
they like to not see you do so well then
like to pull you down to their level
North Las Vegas Police say charges
against both brothers will eventually be
based on the fact that the victim
eventually died live from North Las
Vegas Brian will 8 News Now